if we bring chomsky back into the
conversation
first of all is it unfair to draw a line
between mathematical
cognition and
language linguistic cognition i think
that's a very interesting question
and i think um it's one of the ones that
i'm actually very interested in right
now
um
but i i think the answer is
in important ways
it is important to draw that line
but then to come back and look at it
again and see
some of the subtleties and interesting
aspects of the difference um
so
if we think
about chomsky himself
um he
uh
was born into an academic family his
father was a professor of rabbinical
studies at a small rabbinical college in
philadelphia
um
and
he was deeply enculturated in
uh
you know a culture of thought and reason
and
brought
to the
effort to understand natural language
this
profound engagement with these formal
systems
and um
you know
i think that
there was tremendous power in that and
that chomsky had some amazing insights
into the structure of natural language
but
that
i'm going to use the word but there
the actual intuitive knowledge of these
things only goes so far and does not go
as far as it does in people like chomsky
himself
and this was something that was
discovered in the phd dissertation of
lyla gleitman who was actually trained
in the same linguistics department with
chomsky
so what lila discovered
was that
the intuitions that linguists had
about
even the meaning of a phrase
not just about its grammar but about
what they thought a phrase
must mean
were very different from the intuitions
of
an ordinary person who wasn't a formally
trained thinker
and
well it recently has become much more
salient i happen to have learned about
this when i myself was a phd student at
the university of pennsylvania but um
i never knew how to put it together with
all of my other thinking about these
things so
so i actually
currently have the hypothesis that
formally trained linguists and other
formally trained
um
academics
whether it be
linguistics philosophy
cognitive science computer science
machine learning mathematics
have a
mode of engagement with experience that
is intuitively
deeply
structured to be more
organized around
the
systematicity
and
ability to be conformed with
the principles of a system than um
then is actually true of the natural
human mind without that immersion that's
fascinating so the different fields and
approaches with which you start to study
the mind actually take you
away from the natural operation of the
mind so it makes it very difficult for
you to
to be somebody who introspects yes
and
you know this is where um
uh
things about
human
belief
and
so-called knowledge
that we
consider
um
private
not our business to
manipulate in others we are not entitled
to tell somebody else what to believe
about
certain kinds of things
um
what are those beliefs well they are the
product of this sort of immersion
and enculturation
uh that is what i believe
so and that's limiting
it's
something to be aware of
does that limit you from uh
having a good model
of some of cognition
you can
so when you look at mathematical or
linguistics so i mean what what is that
line then
what um
so is chomsky unable to sneak up to the
full picture of cognition are you when
you're focusing on mathematical
uh thinking are you also unable to do so
i think you're you're right i think
that's a great way of characterizing it
and um
i also think
that
um it's related to
um the concept of beginner's mind
and um
another concept called the expert blind
spot
so
the expert blind spot is much more
prosaic seeming than than this
point that you were just making but it's
it's something that plagues
experts
when they try to communicate their
understanding to non-experts and that is
that
things are self-evident to them
they they can't begin to even think
about how they could explain it to
somebody else because it's like well
it's just
like so patently obvious that it must be
true
and
um
you know like
when
kronecker said
god made the natural numbers all else is
the work of man he was expressing that
that intuition
that um somehow or other
you know the basic fundamentals of
discrete quantities being countable and
innumerable and you know indefinite in
number
um
was was not something that
had to be
discovered um
but he was wrong it turns out that
uh many cognitive scientists agreed with
him for a time there was a long period
of time where there were
where um you know the natural numbers
were considered to be
a part of the innate endowment of
you know core knowledge or
you know to use the kind of phrases that
uh spelke and and kerry use to talk
about what they believe are the innate
primitives of the human mind
and
um they no longer believe that they it's
actually
um
been more or less accepted by almost
everyone that the natural numbers are
actually a cultural construction
and it's it's so interesting to go back
and sort of like study those few people
who still exist who you know who don't
have those systems
so so this is just an example to me
and
where you know a certain mode of
thinking about language itself or a
certain mode of thinking about
geometry and
those kinds of relations so becomes so
second nature that you don't know what
it is that you need to teach
[Music]
and um
and in fact we don't really teach it all
that explicitly anyway and
it's it's you know
you take a math class the professor sort
of teaches it to you the way they
understand it
some of the students in the class sort
of like you know they get it they start
to get the way of thinking and they can
actually do the problems that get
get put on the homework that the
professor thinks are interesting and
challenging ones but
but
most of the students who don't
kind of engage as deeply don't ever get
you know and
we
we think oh that man must be brilliant
he must have this special insight but i
you know he must have some you know
biological sort of bit that's different
right that makes him so that he or she
could have that insight but i
i'm
although i don't want to dismiss
biological individual differences
completely i
i find it much more interesting to think
about the possibility that
um
you know it was that difference in the
dinner table conversation at the chomsky
house when he was growing up that made
it so that he had that cast of mind
you